france was the fourth nation to acquire
nuclear weapons
the first three had built theirs off of
the work done during the manhattan
project with the usa doing the leg work
the uss are stealing secrets from the
u.s fire espionage and the uk via
essentially copying america's homework
but france's route becoming a nuclear
power was different and fraught with its
own problems
so how did france do it how did france
acquire nuclear weapons
so as of the end of world war ii france
wasn't completely new to nuclear
technology and some of its own
scientists had worked on the manhattan
project under the british umbrella
so at the end of the 1940s the french
government started a nuclear program
with the help of israeli scientists
whose aid was fundamentally moving the
project along
at first the nuclear program was
civilian in nature and france very
quickly became a world leader in the
building of nuclear reactors
naturally having civilian nuclear power
meant that nuclear armament was much
easier because of all of that spare
refined nuclear material just lying
around
in 1956 after the suez crisis france was
left internationally humiliated and felt
that neither the usa nor the uk could be
relied upon to use their nuclear weapons
in the defense of france
as such the french sought to build their
own and briefly actively worked with
west germany and italy to build nuclear
arsenals for all three
this was scrapped when charles de gaulle
became president in late 1958 since he
wanted france's nuclear program to be as
self-sufficient as possible
a side effect of this decision was that
unlike the british program the french
one was incredibly expensive and was a
major drain on other parts of the french
military
and the reason for this was that unlike
when britain began building nuclear
weapons the us was hostile to the idea
not hostile enough to do anything about
it but american leadership made it clear
that it felt that france did not need
its own nuclear weapons
and as such they got zero help from the
us which increased the cost of the
program
so why allow britain but not france well
it was because france's nuclear strategy
was going to be fundamentally different
from britain's
you see britain had largely agreed to
maintain the same deterrent policy as
the united states
one which called for response in kind no
escalation and no first strike
whereas france had different plans
french leadership believed that an
invasion by the ussr could only be
stopped with a nuclear retaliation
meaning the soviets would have a choice
invade and lose half of ukraine and
belarus or retaliate with their own
nukes
and a soviet nuclear attack would then
force a response from the uk and the usa
since radiation doesn't care for borders
which for the french meant that they
could effectively force the use of
british and american arsenals if they
wanted to
you can see why the two weren't so keen
french and israeli scientists continued
in collaboration until france had
constructed and tested its first bomb in
1960.
the test was carried out in algeria and
was probably followed by israeli
scientists being dismissed from the
programme and also a lot of grumbling
from the ussr and mild annoyance from
the usa
algeria gained its independence in 1962
but the french continued to test there
until the mid-1960s where they changed
their primary testing site to french
polynesia
by 1964 france had its first operational
nuclear weapons and would go on to
expand its arsenal throughout the cold
war
and thus the french had despite varying
levels of opposition from the other
nuclear powers joined the club as its
fourth member
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker danny
maloney marvin cassell the pastry
section rob waterhouse
moe aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley gustav swann marcus asner
jerry lamdin
rasheed ali cooling castleman spinning
three plates david silverman maggie
paxkowski
coppertone izzy spencer lightfoot fobo
joe matthew shipley
robert wetzel lexi schwinn and winston k
wood